pédaler c'est très bien c'est merci pan
merci mon pan après on est quand même
dans une génération d'offensé hein
ouais merci
Géraldine merci gér vous VO c'est vrai
les chéris vous avez vu cette histoire
euh il y a un appel à lide très original
suite à l'absence prolongée de leur
professeur de français les élèves du
collège Alain Fournier qui peut me citer
un livre d'Alain fourni le grand moule
Grandou bravo exactement le grand mul
oui j'ai pas de j'ai pas d'oreillette
moi j'ai Leurent fourni le grand mol
exactement et oui Alain fourni le grand
mort pendant la guerre 14 don corps a
été retrouvé des décennies plus tard il
déroule il
déroule il tout faire il déroule les
gars c'est une déroulade oh ah non
franchement c'est une
déroulade bah c'est un collège qui est
dans l'Indre en Inde il se retrouve
privé de cours depuis le 17
octobreindre mais Morgane maellie Cléa
et Eugénie qure élèves de 6e ne veulent
pas rester les bras croisés alors signé
par l'ensemble des élèves ils ont décidé
d'interpeller Brigit Macron dans une
lettre volontairement remplie de fautes
d'orthographe pour dire bah quand on a
plus de preuve de français on fait des
fautes ETTI tata regardez j'ai bien
aimer cette petite Darca ou c'était
sympathique et d'ailleurs ils ont fait
le buz grâce à çay tout le monde en
parle et ils vont certainement voir ils
ont récupéré de deux prof voilà voilà
voilà mais c'est génial bah oui c'est
génial
ouais- gé mais moi je peux plus non mais
je te jure mais frères e maises frèrees
tu es le mec le plus RAC que je
connaisse au monde mais sans ch je te
jure que c'est vrai je pense qu'il y a
pas un gars plus rassera que toi pous
Palomba il pousse Palomba plutôt non
mais Palomba est plus sympathique si si
Palomba quand même elle te raconte des
histoires Palomba elle te dit ouais il y
a un il a mis une canette dans le rectum
vent tu vois tu kiffes un peu avec elle
tu vois lui il arrive c'est que des mais
frère mais mais V tout mais quitte-le
bordel non non mais sans déconner
parre-toi V tout fais tes valises vas-y
ma chérie non mais sans déconner
répéteriez les yeux dans les yeux que je
suis moins sympathique que palombba ah
mais de loin je préfère 1000 fois
Palomba ça toi je te dis tu es le mec le
plus racera que je connaisse au mond
c'est même pas fat kitle qui choqué
c'est regardez non mais sans
déconner l'absentéisme des professeurs
est un véritable fléo pour de nombreux
établissements scolaires et dans l'Indre
alors que trois classes de collège
étaient resté sans professeur de
français plusieurs élèves de 6e ont pris
l'initiative d'envoyer une lettre à
Brigitte Macron elle-même anciennement
enseignante de français une lettre
volontairement truffée de faut
d'orthographe pour mieux interpell sur
le sujet nous voudrions une prof de
français cela fait 2 mois que l'on n'a
pas de prof de français et nous trouvons
ça inadmissible une démarche qui semble
avoir porté ses fruits puisque deux
professeurs de français auraient
désormais été
trouvés bravo bravo
bravoce qu'il veut non mais ça peut pas
être la France ça c'estàd que maintenant
pour que les enfants est un enseignant
il faut écrire à la première dame une
lettre ru fait de faute faire le buzz
vous rendez compte o on en est un lycée
un établissement scolaire sur deux qui
manque au moins d'un prof mais vas-y toi
et pour avoir tu es pas prof toi
d'ailleurs si si mais moi j'aime bien il
y a aucun de tes élèves qui s'est
distingué bizarrement ils sont contents
mais non mais moi j'adore j'ai toujours
enseigné aux jeunes et tout ça mais non
mais il faut enseigner il faut
transmettre le savoir et ça Cyril ça ne
va pas d'accord on ne doit pas non mais
on doit pas écrire à la première dame
pour avoir un prof c'est une
vanarrête un peu ils ont bien fait bien
s c'est un coup projecteur compris soci
bien sûr oui mais B enfin qu'on écve
cette lettre àcron et GAB ça veut dire
elle par qu'elle é prof de français les
gars mais si ça mettre en lumière ce
truc ce que dénonce Gill bah c'est
chouette aussi elle l'ont fait et ça
servira peut-être pour d'autres et je
sais pas j'essie de voir ça un peu
naïvement un coup projecteur il sont dit
on va en parler et et on va être sûr que
localement le l'histoire va être réglé
parce que elle est les prof de français
et lui dès qu'on parle de l'école il se
met dans tous ces état mais c'est comme
l'uniforme hier il pas d nu ça faitcho
ça fait chcho vous il y a pas de prof il
manque plein de choses dans les écoles
mais vous voulez mettre 200 balles dans
des uniformes prenez des profs déjà
avant de mettre des uniformes venez on
fait d'abord les vous nous faites chier
ver vas c'est très
graves ce côtél son je peux
plus donc c'est rmon et moi qui vous
dérange oui parce qu'on est pas content
par qu'il y a pas de prof ou non mais en
fait Jacques ta dit ils sont malins ils
ont fait le buzz en fait c'est pas ça
gouverner en fait c'est pas faire le buz
la société d'aujourd'hui ne fonctionne
que comme ça donc eux ils se sont dit
comment on peut faire pour avoir un prof
tu trou un problème que la société
fonctionne comme
ça
imp pas train de dire que c'est bien je
suis en train de me mettre à la place de
ces gamins qui ont été très malin en se
disant comment on peut attirer
l'attention sur ils ont attiré
l'attention en imaginant un truc qui
avait pas été
faitors pardon mais c'est aussi dirigé
par les parents parce que tu crois
vraiment quand on est élève a 11s on ve
desam de gamins l'ID quand on est gamin
on veut pas on
B aujourd'hui par ex par exemple
aujourd'hui moi c'est j'ai eu ce
sentiment ce matin je devais avoir mon
coach je devais j'avais rendez-vous avec
mon coach à à 10h et à 8h il a annulé il
m'a envoyé je suis malade comme un chien
c'est peut-être pas bon qu'on s'entraîne
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être pas bon pour
toi pas de problème tumerde
pas t'emmerde pas je vais aller
m'entraîner tout seul ah mais écoute-moi
bien quand j'ai vu ça j'ai la même
sensation que quand tu es dans le
couloir à l'école tu sais tuattends et
tu sais il y avait toujours normalement
un couloir et normalement la prof tu l'
vois arrivé de loin 14h
14h5 14h10 elle vient pas elle vient pas
et là tu entendais tu entendais les
talons
merain les gars est
làain elle sortait les clés au fond du
couloir comm allez on
y tu te dépch alors moi j'avis une
techque après parce que j'étais délégué
de classe et donc dès que la prof 5
minutes de retard j'allais voir les
élèves les gars bon allez on y va je
viens avoir l'info la prof n'est pas là
il faut tous qu'on y aille je vous jure
que c'est vrai et combien fois c'est pas
le meilleur de la classe combien et
combien de fois et ben on est parti
intercept et et donc on partait et on
allait après on pouvait pas partir parce
qu'on avait cours après donc on était en
classe de perme tout ça et la prof gen
une demheure après elle nous cherchait
partout elle arriv mais qu'est-ce que
vous faites là mais non mais parce Queen
fait ils ont dit que vous étiez pas làad
mais bon il reste 20 minutes vous croyez
vraiment que c'est on va se déplacer
tout ça pour rien ser à rien on reste
ici et puis on se revoit la prochaine
fois non allez allez tu prends tes
affaires tu
vas combien de fois je les fa je dis on
se revoit la prochaine fois ça va madame
c'est bon 2 minutes s non mais c'est
vrai et je vous l'avais dit ça ce que je
faisais quand je voulais pas me
réveiller le matin j'étais délégué
j'appelais toute la classe oui et je
disais genre la prof du soire est pas là
dem on avait histoire de 8 à 10 et moi
j'étais fracasse je sortais souvent moi
quand j'étais en premiierre et tout je
sortais le soir et donc j'étais j'étais
éclaté je savais que j'allais re éclaté
donc j' appelis tout le monde dis ouais
bon demain on démarre à 10h ouais non je
viens d'avoir le mari de la prof
d'histoire le mari le mari je vous jure
que c'est vrai je vous jure que c'est
vrai elle est pas bien madame journac
elle est pas là demain ouais bah 10h
demain ouais ok Salut Les Chéries salut
et je me rappelle on est arrivé tous à
10h qu'est-ce que tu voulais qu'elle
dise et moi et moi jeis mais ouais bah
elle remontait pas la filière c'est pas
moi c'est moi c'est jamais moi qui t'ai
appelé voilà et donc voilà donc je le
dis ne le faites
pas quoi votre maman elle le sait ça ou
elle l'prend ce soir en direct non mais
elle sait tout ma mère elle était
fourrée elle était plus au collège que
moi frère dès que je sortais de la la
salle il y avait ma mère tu le
conseiller de d'éducation donc je
t'explique elle était plus plus là-bas
que moi non non voilà vous inquiétez pas
mais ne le faites pas chez vous on va
parler à la Tintin au Congo ah Gill la
bande dessinée aura maintenant une
nouvelle couverture une préface pour ne
plus choquer on va en
parler à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]